[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum internationalen
Frühschoppen an diesem Sonntagmittag aus
Köln in dieser Woche schaut die Welt
nach Vilnius zum NATO-Gipfel die Staats-
und Regierungschefs von 31 NATO-Staaten
beraten dort vor allem über das Land das
noch kein Mitglied der NATO ist die
Ukraine Präsident silenski drängt auf
eine Einladung in das Bündnis und
überraschend die Aussage des türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan der den Beitritt der
Ukraine unterstützt 500 Tage dauert der
russische Angriffskrieg nun an es ist
kein Ende in Sicht und die Nachricht
dass die USA jetzt treu Munition liefern
wollen für zu neuen Diskussionen auch in
Deutschland vor dem Gipfel in Vilnius
gehört die Ukraine in die NATO darüber
spreche ich mit diesen Gästen herzlich
willkommen Katherine Klüver esbrook sie
ist amerikanisch deutsche
politikwissenschaftlerinnen und
Publizistin und ziehen ja etwa der
Bertelsmannstiftung ich begrüße dr sehr
geh zum Lenny Gründer und Direktor des
europeanische Centers und Autor er ist
in Russland geboren und hat dort
Journalismus studiert und hat Büro der
böllstiftung in Kiew geleitet herzlich
willkommen Thomas Meyer Korrespondent
für die EU und die NATO aus Brüssel für
die österreichische Tageszeitung der
Standard und ich begrüße Thomas
schleemann er ist Deutschland
Korrespondent in Berlin für den privaten
polnischen Fernsehsender TV Polsat News
und das Portal interior und sie sind wie
immer auch eingeladen anzurufen oder
sich wieder Twitter oder Facebook zu
beteiligen bevor wir über die Ukraine
und die NATO sprechen Frau
klüvereschbruck würde ich gerne noch mal
den Blick werfen auf die Nachricht die
doch alle jetzt etwas aufgeregt hat
nämlich die Ankündigung der USA
Streumunition in die Ukraine zu liefern
wir erinnern uns daran dass Russland das
eingesetzt hat das wurde schwerstens
verurteilt die sehen Sie jetzt diese
angekündigung also ich Tatsache dass wir
diese Diskussion haben müssen zeig doch
einfach in welcher ernsthaften
Situationen für uns befinden also noch
mal russland hat Streumunition schon
seit Beginn des Krieges eingesetzt mit
einer Fehlerquote einer blindgängerquote
von 30 bis 40 Prozent also damit
effektiv die Ostukraine vermiet
zusätzlich zu dem was sie auch gemacht
haben das heißt diese Antwort der
Amerikaner wenn man das mal so sehen
möchte liegt daran dass wir zum Teil
einfach nicht schnell genug das
geliefert haben was die Ukraine nämlich
ursprünglich gefordert hat nämlich
erstmal
Artilleriemunition 155 mm 1:05 mm das
wollten sie haben und das konnten wir in
der Schnelligkeit kann der Westen nicht
mehr liefern das heißt im ersten Moment
ist die Ankündigung Streumunition zu
liefern einspielen auf Zeit auch eins
was abgekapselt sein könnte zeitlich
sobald der Westen quasi wieder das
liefern kann was die Ukraine nämlich
wirklich verlangt klassische Munition
das ist die eine Sache die andere Sache
und das ist ganz wichtig noch mal in der
Einordnung was ist das für Munition ist
dass die Streumunition die die
Amerikaner liefern wollen das hat der
Pentagon äh gerade noch mal vor
anderthalb Tagen gesagt eine
strömmunition ist die eine Fehlerquote
von unter
2,35% hat und dass diese streumun Person
flankiert werden soll zweierlei a mit
den Zusicherungen der Ukraine
schriftlich dass sie diese Munition
nicht über stark bewohntem Gebiet oder
ihren eigenen Städten einsetzen wollen
und zweitens dass dieses dass diese
Munition begleitet wird von Minen Räumen
Fahrzeugen und einen weiteren
finanziellen Zusicherung das Land dann
auch parallel quasi schon zu entminen 95
Millionen Dollar haben die Amerikaner
allein schon dafür ausgegeben das heißt
es geht Streumunition ist immer
wiederlich ist immer abscheulich da
möchte ich nicht falsch wahrgenommen
werden aber es geht hier um
unterschiedliche Bereiche und es geht
hier um unterschiedliche strategische
Nutzung okay es Träume ist geächtet von
vielen Ländern Herstellung Produktion
und weiter Verbreitung durch das Osloer
Abkommen Person auch an Sie die Frage
als die Russen Ströme Munition
eingesetzt haben sie haben jetzt gesagt
das war eine andere Art trotzdem ähm was
bedeutet das jetzt und wenn die Ukraine
bekommt macht die Ukraine sich dann
nicht sozusagen auch moralisch noch mal
stärker angreifen
kein Problem mit dem Moral hier seit der
Ukraine zuerst man muss verstehen also
jede Krieg ist schrecklich klar also da
sind wir alle eigentlich also nur warum
war die strommunition von vielen Ländern
verboten einseitig wie gesagt so diese
Konvention zu strohemunition Verbot ist
kein Tal des internen Zahlen
kommunizieren rechts und ist kein Tal
von in dem internationalen Recht also
dafür gibt es zu wenig Länder am Boden
ist kein Teil vom us-korganis also es
ist die Verpflichtung
ja aber das ist immer noch kein Teil vom
internationalen Recht in juristisches
Sinne das ist die Verpflichtung dieser
Länder und kein Land mit der Ausnahme
von Norwegen was ein Landesgrenze zu
Russland hat hat diese Konvention
unterzeichnet auch nicht Polen nicht
Finnland nicht Rumänien und die anderen
warum weil man diese Munition man
versteht deswegen in Russland angreift
man kann diese Masse der russischen
Soldaten nur mit massiven Einsatz der
Waffen stoppen und Strom Position ist
wäre dann sie Antwort jetzt zu Ihre
Frage die Russen benutzen die
strohhalmunitionen gegen die Wohngebiete
und gegen die dichtbesinnten Gebiete das
da gibt es unzählige Videos wie die
dicht besiedelten
wohnsilogebiete attackiert worden waren
und das war das kriegt der
Kriegsverbrechen nicht selbst die
Benutzung der strohemmunition wem die
Ukraine jetzt wir gaben den Russen ein
Jahr lang um sich äh um diese
Verteidigungspositionen auszubauen
Gräber bauen minenfelde diese Gebete im
Süden der Ukraine sind schon jetzt die
am meisten verseuchten Gebiete durch die
Minen weltweit das verseuchte
minengebiet ist dreimal größer als
Österreich so groß wie das Vereinigte
Königreich fast die Hälfte von
Deutschland stehen
die Ukraine jetzt durch diese
minengräber durchgreifen wollen wenn Sie
diese Gräber voll mit russischen von
Tilly du sprechen wollen dann brauchen
Sie diese Grebe zuerst attackieren und
dafür ist stromunition das beste Mittel
es wird aber eigentlich als Argument ja
gesagt das ist deshalb geliefert weil
die andere Munition eben momentan
produziert werden kann die Ukraine genug
high explosiv Munition damit sie diese
Gräbe dann mit 10 20 30 Geschosse
Beziehungs attackieren können dann
hätten sie Strömung so nicht gebraucht
die haben das nicht und eine
stromunition bedeckt dann ein großes
Feld wo die russischen Batterie ist wo
sowieso die Minen da sind und das bringt
im Prinzip das verschlechtet nicht die
Situation dass ganz im Gegenteil das
Rede dazu kriegen also Sie beides haben
Argumente dafür gebracht herr Meier wird
damit aber nicht trotzdem eine Linie
überschritten es sind ja auch einige
Länder auch NATO Mitglieder die eben
genau diese den Einsatz von verurteilen
Deutschland z.B an erster Stelle also es
ist wie gesagt dann was das gut erklärt
ich sehe keinen Gipfel jetzt zwei
Probleme aufkommen das eine ist dass dir
das Lager Europäer gespalten wird die an
Russland angrenzenden Staaten
werden tendenziell dafür sein auch wenn
sie es vielleicht nicht laut sagen für
Deutschland ist das sehr schwierig auch
für andere NATO-Staaten vor allem Invest
Europa das zweite ist dass diese dieses
Faktum zeigt dass die lange erwartete
Gegenoffensive der ukrainischen Armee
offenbar nicht so gut funktioniert wie
man wenn Sie sich erinnern vor ein paar
Monaten noch gehofft hat es geht die
Munition aus man muss jetzt auf Streu
Munition zurückgreifen weil die Europäer
nicht in der Lage waren zu liefern wie
das eigentlich geplant war und wie man
das eigentlich wollte es gibt die
berühmte zahlen dass die ukrainische
Armee pro Monat ungefähr so viel Arterie
verschießt wie die Europäer im Moment
überhaupt produzieren können und ich
denke dieses Problem ist entstanden und
amerikanische Präsident beiden hat das
zu meinem Erstaunen auch sehr offen
gestern gesagt oder vorgestern ich weiß
nicht mehr genau wann das eben zu wenig
Munition da ist und dass man deswegen
darauf zurückgreifen muss und weil das
so ist wird es sehr sehr schwer sein
beim Gipfel sich dagegen auszusprechen
explizit also ich vermute mal man wird
beim Gipfel versuchen sich da irgendwie
herum zu manövrieren ohne sich da genau
festzulegen
dass man stärker und schneller
produziert diese andere Munition Herr
Lehmann wird das überhaupt wird das in
Polen diskutiert spielt das eine Rolle
die Diskussion die jetzt natürlich auch
in Deutschland schon auch ja zu einer
Debatte geführt hat wieder ich habe
jetzt gerade noch die die letzte
Kommentare mir angeschaut und sein
offiziellen Statement zum Thema
strömonission sehe ich nicht aber ich
gehe davon aus dass es auch einfach ein
schwieriges Thema weil von einer Seite
hat Polen dieses Konvention nicht
unterschrieben und Meinung ist klar dass
das Ukraine hat rechts auch selbst
Verteidigung und das was von russische
Seite passiert das wissen wir alles aber
ich gehe davon aus dass dieses Thema
auch wird bei dem Gipfel eine Rolle auch
auf der polnische Seite spielen weil zum
diesem Thema wissen wir dass wir haben
europäische Partner die sind dagegen im
großen Teil aber wir haben einen
Amerikaner die dieses Vorschlag jetzt
gegeben haben
und
orientiert sich vor allem wenn dies um
diese Sicherheit Fragen an die
Amerikaner also ich gehe davon aus dass
dieses Thema wird schon eine Rolle auch
an diesem Gipfel Spielen dieser Gipfel
ist besonders wichtig
weil wir natürlich eben genau auf die
Ukraine so stark schauen jetzt gab es
die Nachricht von Erdogan die zweite
Nachricht die nach der Lieferung von
streumonotation noch mal glaube ich alle
aufgerüttelt hat ist das der türkische
Präsident Erdogan gesagt hat das ist
sinnvoll wenn die Ukraine in die NATO
kommt Herr Meier wie bewerten sie das
denn das ist ja eigentlich doch eher
überraschend also das Land das nicht
will das Schweden mit Dieter NATO wird
aber jetzt sagt die Ukraine
sagen wir mal so Erde werden spielt eine
Rolle eine große Rolle in diesem ganzen
Konflikt als Vermittler er versucht sich
zu positionieren und das auch zu
verstärken ja die angekündigt dass der
russische Präsident
Putin nach Ankara kommen wird um über
das getreideabkommen zu verhandeln oder
über die gesamte Situation selensky hat
in dieser Tage besucht also er
positioniert sich sozusagen sehr zentral
als großer Player bei diesem Gipfel weil
er natürlich auch was will das ist eine
übliche Methode er möchte vor allem von
den Amerikanern F16 Jäger bekommen ich
denke wir können davon ausgehen dass es
sehr lange und intensive Gespräche geben
wird zwischen beiden und Präsident
Erdogan und da wird dann auch
verschiedene Deals geben in diesem
Zusammenhang dass er ausgerechnet gegen
Schweden auftritt und für die Ukraine
ist natürlich ein ein
eine gewisse Pointe weil das von der
Sache ja überhaupt nicht gerechtfertigt
ist weil die Ukraine weit weg ist von
einem NATO betritt Schweden hingegen
wäre so wie Finnland auch natürlich
sofort bereit aber er verwendet das
sozusagen als eine Art Geiselnahme für
seine eigenen innenpolitischen Ziele
auch natürlich wie hat man das in der
Ukraine diese Nachricht selenski war ja
auch in Istanbul das jetzt so klar sich
Erdogan dafür ausgesprochen hat ist
natürlich positiv wahrgenommen also die
Ukraine hat natürlich mit Erdogan die
komplizierte Geschichte der Verhältnisse
da Erdogan spielte zum Teil proaktiv
auch der ukrainischen Seite dann denken
wir mit der über diese Zusammenarbeit
von dem drohnenproduzenten Biker von äh
von der Türkei welche diese Drohnen bei
Radar die zwei produziert oder z.B diese
Rolle von Erdogan in Getreide Diehl oder
diese Garantien
ukrainischen Kriegsgefangenen welche
Russland dann an der Türkei geliefert
hat also das war gut in gleichzeitig
spielt also spielt er dann praktisch auf
zwei auf zwei Hochzeiten und ja versucht
auch seine Verhältnisse mit Russland
nicht zu ich glaube das ist aber die
typische die typische Außenpolitik der
Türkei und die Ukraine nehmen das
gelassen diese Unterstützung der Worte
von Erdogan sind gut und ich glaube dass
je mehr nahezu Länder das verstehen dass
die Ukraine ein asset ein Vorteil für
NATO wäre und mit der Ukraine an Bord
wäre nach der Stärke und die Lage wäre
sicherer und nicht gefährliche desto
besser wäre es das hat die Frage darüber
reden meiner Meinung
was die wichtig ist so eine Aussage von
Erdogan hat das irgendein Einfluss auf
die Haltung der Amerikaner auf die
Erhaltung der Amerikaner wird es wenig
Auswirkungen haben das sind sie wie
gesagt gewöhnt von Herrn Erdogan dass er
da taktische Spielchen spielt dass er
sich als kingmaker produziert dass er
immer mal wieder Feuer oder Öl streut je
nachdem was gerade in seinen innen und
außenpolitisches Kalkül reinpasst es ist
interessant dass auch wenn es andere
Länder versucht haben
die Brasilianer und andere und
Amerikaner in diesem Krieg in
irgendeiner Weise zu vermitteln dass an
Erdogan trotzdem immer noch wie gesagt
dieses kingmaker Image kleben kann denn
er ist wirklich also wie die einzigen
zwei diplomatischen Kontakte her ist und
wenn ja schon angesprochen die noch
existieren sind die zum
Gefangenenaustausch und die zum
weizenaustausch am 17 Juli soll das da
weitergehen in den Verhandlungen und das
wären wirklich die Türöffner Russland in
irgendeiner Weise an den Tisch zu holen
denn bislang signalisiert ja Russland
überhaupt keine Bereitschaft dazu das
heißt auf ein erdogan ist schultern
könnten mitunter wenn er sich diesen ja
westlichen Rucksack anschnallen möchte
auch noch mehr Verantwortung liegen aber
ob er das macht und ob das wiederum
irgendwie in seinem eigenen Kalkül wäre
das steht aus also da steht immer noch
unter großer Frage es geht dabei darum
sozusagen Sicherheitsgarantien der
Ukraine zu gehen wie auch immer ob
Beitritt oder in welcher Form
wie sollte das ist das aus polnischer
Perspektive wie wichtig ist das und mit
welchem Erwartungen schaut man da auf
den hatte ganz wichtig das Produkt hat
vor allem für Polen ist das tatsächlich
Schweden in der NATO kommt weil dann
wird die quasi dieses
Region rund um baltik einfach
miteinander abgeschlossen aber noch zum
Thema Erdogan was ich wollte auch sagen
wir wissen ganz genau dass der erdogan
ist ein sehr guter Player auch im
innenpolitisch und
das war tatsächlich gestern überrascht
und das habe ich mich schon gefragt was
ist da passiert das tatsächlich er hat
gegen Russland gespielt obwohl im
Wahlkampf man hat dieses Gefühl dass er
einfach zumindest auch bei den trolling
und so weiter ist unterstützt vom
Russland Seite und alle hatten dieses
Gefühl dass nach dem Wahlkampf er muss
das irgendwie alles zurückzahlen
aber vielleicht in dieser Strategie mit
Ukraine ist einfach ein Teil von einer
Ablenkung von inneren Problemen in der
Türkei bei Türkei steckt in einer
tieferkrise und diese internationalen
Themen wo er kann sich einer ein großer
Politiker zeigen können so ein bisschen
diese Probleme so ein bisschen ablenken
und das ist das glaube ich dass das kann
eine Rolle spielen dann geht's um
ich kann mich an kein naturgipfel
erinnern und auch Auftritte von Erde
dann in Brüssel bei der EU wo er nicht
diese Rolle gespielt hätte das muss man
glaube ich wissen er versucht halt immer
wieder und interessanterweise kommt da
ganz oft damit durch deswegen ist das
für ihn auch wenn er eigentlich keine
Strategie dahinter hat sondern eher
begleiteter ist geht es für ihn meistens
auch aber das gelingt nur weil wir so
die weil Deutschland und die anderen
Länder welche sich selbst als große
nato-parteien malen was sie natürlich
nicht schauen wir auch die Größe und
Kampffähigkeit der Bundeswehr in weil
wir uns so
sympathisch und passiv verhalten also
hätten wir ein aktive Rolle genommen in
diesem Krieg hätten wir Waffen geliefert
hätten wir die Führung gezeigt dann
hätten wir wieder die Türkei noch China
noch Brasil Brasilien gebraucht also der
Vakuum muss gefüllt werden und der
Vakuum entsteht klar wenn wir jetzt alle
an beiden schauen denken oh was wird
beiden sagen wird er Waffen liefern wird
der f600
Munition welche ein Katastrophe da warum
schauen wir alle auf beiden auf seine
Entscheidungen weil wir nichts machen
und dass sie das Problem also
deutschland ist nach den USA der größte
Unterstützer in Lieferung an die Ukraine
man kann ja nicht sagen sollte
eigentlich Wahnsinn aber ja in den
letzten Monaten mit großem Abstand und
auch ein Großteil von diese
Unterstützung war finanzielle Natur was
wichtig war nicht so nicht zu bestreiten
aber wir haben dieses Problem erschaffen
selbst wir haben Russland ein Jahr Zeit
gegeben wir haben die Ukraine nur bis
zum Niveau unterstützt sie überleben
aber unten weiter und jetzt fragen wir
warum warum ist die ukrainische
Offensive so langsam ich bin nicht dann
verstanden dass ich scheitert sie kommt
gut voran aber sehr langsam warum ist
der langsam weil die Russen ein Jahr
Langzeit hatten um alle diese Gräbe zu
bauen um ihnen fällt dazu liegen und
malerie zu positionieren um die neuen
Leute zu rekrutieren dann fragen wir
warum können die Ukraine mit 20 Leopard
2 Panzer diese diese diese Linie nicht
brechen ohne luftdominanz kein NATO Land
hätte je so eine offensive gestartet
ohne luftdominanz und Ukraine müssen
jetzt tun das ist die klassische
Herausforderung für die NATO und die
jetzt ihr strategische Konzept was sie
immer tritt verabschiedet haben in die
Umsetzung bringen müssen nämlich zu
verstehen einerseits sich eigentlich
jahrelang auf einen technologisch
hochgerüsteten Kampf vorbereitet zu
haben ja wo strategische Streitkräfte
konventionelle Streitkräfte eigentlich
keine Rolle mehr spielen und auf einmal
stehen sie einem geraden Krieg gegenüber
wo diese Dinge alle wieder eine
riesengroße Rolle spielen und wo es
jetzt wirklich darum geht wie schnell
kann man Bataillone im Privaten
umwandeln sie ja auch das Zugeständnis
des deutschen Verteidigungs ist das
gerade die deutsche Präsenz als Teil von
enhance forward presents nicht nur
permanent zu machen sondern daraus auch
quasi eine brigadengröße zu stellen all
das sind neue Überlegungen also dieser
Gipfel wirklich und es gibt ein
grundsätzlich neues Konzept von dem
Oberkommandeur der NATO in Europa von
Chris Cavalli durch diese tausenden von
Seiten werden sich auf dem NATO-Gipfel
die Kollegen durcharbeiten müssen um
diesen Dreisprung hinzubekommen erstens
quasi die NATO wieder abschreckungsfähig
zu machen im konventionellen Sinne
Krisen festzumachen für alles was da
kommt auch im cyberbereich und diese
kooperative also das wirklich alles
Inter operabel ist das ist also dass wir
wirklich eine NATO bauen die die
nächsten 20 Jahre über wirklich all
diese Dinge gleichzeitig liefern kann
das sind die großen Herausforderungen
sie fahren nach Vilnius sie berichten ja
schon lange über die NATO ist das so ein
besonderer Gipfel oder ist es eben
einfach der der Tatsache gestaltet dass
wir jetzt schon im zweiten Jahr das
Kriege Wissen history die Kollegin hat
angesprochen
wir sollten nicht den Fehler machen zu
glauben dass das hier in Ukraine Gipfel
ist das natürlich ist Ukraine der
Auslöser aller dieser Entwicklungen die
wir sehen aber
von wegen Abschreckung es geht nicht um
konventionelle Abschreckung
der Staat Abkommen aufgekündigt hat das
ist glaube ich jetzt die Mitte Juli auch
das für ein Thema sein
und der Kollege ist angesprochen ich
glaube dass wir in unserer Zeit erleben
30 Jahre nach dem Zusammenbruch dass
Sowjetunion und nach einer europäischen
Neuordnung wo wir alle geglaubt haben
dass wir friedlich sein dass wir
demokratisch sein es bringt die Buch von
von Fukuyama das Ende der Geschichte
könnte man umbringen sind erst am Anfang
wieder der Geschichte unruhigen
Geschichte Europas
und darum geht es bei diesem Gipfel
jetzt auch es gibt keine neutralen
Staaten mehr im Norden das ist ein ganz
wesentlicher Einschnitt wer hätte sich
das gedacht vor fünf Jahren das Schweden
und Finnland auf einmal noch
wenn ich das noch sagen darf Deutschland
hat plötzlich eine ganz zentrale Rolle
in Brüssel sowohl in der EU als auch in
der NATO sprechen alle davon dass
Deutschland die militärische Führung
übernehmen soll wer hätte sich vor fünf
Jahren gedacht dass man das in Europa
sagen kann Briten sind ausgetreten aus
der EU also diese Neuordnung findet
statt sowohl in der EU als auch in der
NATO durch viele Detail Beschlüsse und
Gespräche auch zur konventionellen
Aufrüstung zur Stationierung von Truppen
was bis zu Ausbruch dieses Ukraine
Krieges ein Tabu war das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen die Nato hatte keine
Truppen in Osteuropa und das ist jetzt
ganz neu jetzt gehen wir sogar von der
bataillonstärke im Brigade Stärke über
von 40.000 Mann der schnellen
Eingreiftruppe der NATO auf 300.000 der
Beschluss von Madrid alles das ist ein
Fluss und das wird Thema beim Gipfel
sein Polen möchte eigentlich auch gerne
noch eine stärkere Rolle in diesem
Verbund haben das ist die neue Idee bei
diesen nuklear sharing das Thema in
Polen ist aufgetaucht weißes Haus jetzt
bedeckt sich und sagt wir wissen davon
in Polen das wird so bisschen anders in
Polen dargestellt dass die Polen wird
eben diesen Bereich eine Rolle spielen
aber wissen wir ganz genau dass Polen
wird keine Rolle in diesem Moment
spielen weil die Waffe wird stationiert
aber die Entscheidungen wie und was wird
das genutzt da andere Länder werden
entscheiden aber was noch sehr wichtig
ich finde an diesem Gipfel ist dann
müssen wir werden nicht nur
gesagt haben nicht nur bei Ukraine
sprechen nur über die wie müssen wir die
NATO gestalten weil wir haben viele
Probleme wie Cyber Probleme das ist ein
großes Problem und das wissen wir was
passiert kurz vor dem Gipfel in diesem
cyberbereich die nächste Sache ist auch
Ostflanke das ist auch ein Thema und
dann anderen Thema ist nach dem hat
versuchte Moskau überfallen wir haben
auch festgestellt dass in vielen
europäischen Ländern auch in Deutschland
alle Geheimdienste
über Jahren diese Fokus auf Russland
abgebaut haben wir wussten überhaupt
nicht was da passiert Pistorius und
Scholz die waren überrascht von diesen
ganzen Ereignissen die waren nicht gut
informiert weil wir aber über Jahren
haben wir Fokus auf islamischen Terror
gestellt werden
sie sehr sehr schnell geteilt und vor
dem Krieg sowieso auch und ich glaube
die das hat man einfach durch die geheim
Diplomatie von dem CIA-Chef Herr uns
jetzt noch mal gesehen ich glaube da
wäre also ich glaube die Amerikaner wenn
man in die Chance geben würden scheiß
als das geheimdienstabkommen jetzt auch
gerne schon erweitern also sie haben
gemerkt dass sie da ein entscheidenden
Vorteil haben und das ist auch den
Europäern dazu Gute käme also
Information ist gerade Goldwert ganz
klar dann machen wir konkreter was würde
es bedeuten oder was erwartet die
Ukraine jetzt konkret von diesem Gipfel
also es wurde ja gesagt wir warten eine
Perspektive dann heißt es aber es soll
den NATO Ukraine Rat geben wäre das nur
ein Trostpreis die Ukraine ja also den
Name selbst so NATO Ukraine Rat wäre für
die Ukraine und ist für die Ukraine
problematisch weil NATO Russland Rat ist
dasselbe was Russland seit 2005 hat und
immer noch hat also das ist das liegt
jetzt auf Eis aber der Rat existieren
selbst und natürlich ist der Inhalt vom
NATO Russland Rat anders als der Inhalt
von dem jetzigen Namen Ukraine Rad aber
für die Ukraine klingt so der Name
selbst ein bisschen wie eine Ohrfeige
warum sollen wir jetzt als eine
Belohnung bekommen sagen die dort in
Kiefer das was die Russen sowieso seit
20 Jahren aber wichtig ist wir haben in
den NATO wir haben seit letztem sagen so
20 30 Jahren wir haben den Zweck diese
NATO Bündnis aufgegeben und der Zweck
war Sicherheit und Frieden in Europa
durch die Länder Aufnahme welche sich
bedroht fühlen welche sich für unsere
Werte deklarieren also für diesen diesen
unseren Werten treu sind und wir
beschützen und Kollektiv dann irgendwo
in den 90ern haben wir gesagt Russland
ist kein NATO Mitglied aber hat ein NATO
Vetorecht Russland darf mitentscheiden
wir rein darf und wer nicht wir haben
praktische Russland mit Vetorecht
belohnt und sie durften jede Zeit ihre
rote Linien ziehen und das das Problem
deswegen also das was von unserer Seite
ihre Zeitung da steht das sicher nicht
aber wir dürfen dieses Land nicht in die
NATO nehmen weil es muss produziert wird
Rituale Probleme haben dürfen nicht in
den Nase weil ich habe mir gesagt wird
die NATO okay also die Nato und da wurde
den Putin praktisch ganz klar gezeigt
wenn du mir ein Land in die zu nicht
zulassen willst dann greifen einfach
dieses Land ein dann hatte das in
Georgien gemacht und in der Ukraine
spielte und jetzt muss es anders gehen
wir müssen die Regeln schaffen wir
müssen wir müssen entscheiden wir in die
NATO darf und wer nicht und wie wir
diesen Sicherheitsraum ausweiten und der
letzte Punkt wenn ich darf wenn die
Ukraine jetzt nicht in die NATO
akzeptiert werden soll ich glaube
persönlich nicht das ist machbar wäre
mit Ungarn und mit anderen Ländern dann
müssen wir quasi in welche Sicherheit
Garantien Ukraine bekommen soll und ihr
sicherer als Garantie müssen sie Form
haben darüber reden
sondern auf ganz konkreten Form mit
Waffen mit Truppen und mit dem ganz
konkreten Schritten welche ohne
Konsultationen und anderen langen
Diskussionen dann eintreten können
Sicherheitsgarantien kommen würde ich
gerne mal hier den Widerspruch hörbar
machen dass das was sie erklärt haben
dass es vielleicht implizit bei Russland
so aufgenommen werden hätte können das
ist aber in keiner Weise in
irgendwelchen Verträgen oder in
irgendeiner Absicht des Westens gewesen
wäre die wer lange aber wie wir lange
2008 und auf auf Anweisungen
Anführungszeichen ist amerikanischen
Präsidenten darum gerungen haben über
einen membership action plan Prozess
einen Aufnahmeprozess errungen haben
aber dann schlussendlich diese Sprache
reingenommen haben dass die Ukraine und
Georgien auf absehbare Zeit Mitglieder
der NATO werden das ist ja durchaus
kontrovers und vielleicht kann man das
dann aus russischer Perspektive so
auslegen das Russland das als
Aufforderung genommen hat sich überall
in der Welt irgendwie einzumischen um
den Westen quasi die Luft zum Atmen
abzuschnüren in Syrien und in Afrika und
natürlich dann in den Grenzregionen etc
das ist historischer fakt aber dass das
in irgendeiner Weise logisch verkettet
sein soll und auf Verträge aufbauen
sollte das wollen wir mal gleich
abstrafen das stimmt so nicht ja
Russland ist natürlich
viel früher sich angemischt und nehmen
sie
transisträder 1992 oder nehmen wir so
den ersten georgischen Krieg von Russen
1993 also die Russen haben die
Passagiermaschine über sucumi im 19 und
1993 abgeschossen bevor Bukarest 2008
bevor diese ganze bevor Aufnahme die
Erde
ich würde da wäre nämlich auch ganz ganz
kurz noch mal eine Frage nur noch als
Anfügung hier eine Frage eines Users der
auf Twitter fragt wie war die Begründung
von Frau Merkel und Herrn Steinmeier
damals die Ukraine nicht in die NATO
aufzunehmender bezieht sich ja auf 2018
zu kommen Merkel hat eine Politik
betrieben und auch die Franzosen
übrigens und das war dahinter Grund
warum beim Nato-Gipfel in Bukarest 2018
daran hat sich bis heute im Prinzip
nichts geändert es hat die FAZ dieser
Tage einen schönen Titel geschrieben
nämlich die NATO ringt um Worte wir
werden sehen bei diesem Gipfel dass man
sagen wird wieder Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg auch schon im Vorfeld gesagt
hat es muss eine Perspektive geben für
die Ukraine was heißt das aber jetzt
Perspektive die Perspektive haben die
schon seit 13 15 Jahren also beiden hat
gesagt die Tür ist offen was heißt dass
die Tür ist offen es muss uns klar sein
dass ein Land das Krieg führend ist das
weder politisch noch wirtschaftlich noch
militärisch in der Lage ist das gilt
übrigens auch für die EU der EU oder der
NATO beizutreten das ist das Status Quo
und jetzt muss man sozusagen eine
Formulierung finden dass die Tür offen
ist die Perspektive weiter da bleibt
aber die Ukraine ist das muss man ganz
klar sagen von einem NATO-Beitritt und
auch von den EU-Beitritt weit weit weg
auf der anderen Seite gehören sie
natürlich zu uns wie die
Kommissionspräsidenten von alleine immer
zu sagen pflegt sie sind Teil der
Familie sie gehören in den Westen in die
freie Welt das ist klar
vorstellt das ist ein langer Prozess
aber zunächst braucht man Frieden und
das ist dass die immer das Beste
auch wenn es keine die rasche
Mitgliedschaft geht sowieso ja nicht in
dem Moment sozusagen
hätten sie auch die Befürchtung dass
eben eine Zusage einer
NATO-Mitgliedschaft für die Ukraine dass
sie sozusagen den den Spielraum für
friedensverhandlung dass das verkleinert
würde dadurch ich glaube vor allem ist
aber nicht jetzt Beobachter auch die die
polnische Politik da glaube ich dass
alle langsam sind pragmatisch dass das
was sie sagen muss Krieg beenden werden
ja das ist das Wichtigste
Zusage eine NATO Mitgliedschaft würde
das eher gegenüber Russland eben eine
Eskalation sein das Russland noch
weniger bereit wäre sich an den Tisch zu
setzen mit dir bringen auf jeden Fall
seine Zusage würde die Situation jetzt
eskalieren aber ehrlich zu sein wenn wir
die die Kreml kennen dann wissen wir
egal was passiert das wird einfach das
für sich nutzen das das auch wenn wir
jetzt die Sicherheit Garantie für die
Ukraine geben dann wird auch
entsprechende Reaktion vom Creme aber
tatsächlich das wichtigste ist jetzt
dass das Krieg wird beenden dass nach
wie vor Ukraine wird stark unterstützt
mehr unterstützt mit mit Waffen und
ich sehe auch so ein bisschen die
Differenzen wegen die Aussagen Ukraine
zur EU und zu NATO da sind zwei komplett
andere Welten weil
EU ist einfach wirtschaftlich politisch
hier engagiert und NATO ist einfach ein
Sicherheit dem also natürlich das
verknüpft man nicht zusammen
ist eine
Annäherung von EU NATO die Europäer
müssen eine wichtige Rolle übernehmen
innerhalb der NATO
die Amerikaner ganz andere Perspektiven
Richtung China wir haben Wahlen nächstes
Jahr wir wissen nicht ob beiden bleibt
oder nicht also diese größere
Verantwortung der Europäer das ist liegt
liegt absolut reden wir schon viele
Jahre an das Ende sich nicht das ist das
ist ja das Problem
muss man auch schon wahrnehmen dass für
Polen die Amerikaner spielen viel
größere Roller als die europäischer
Partner innerhalb von NATO
weil dieses Gefühl ist einfach ein
coolen Zeitung innerhalb der EU liegt
zwei ganz kurze Punkte vielleicht noch
zur EU und NATO also Artikel 42 7 oder
die Aufnahme der Ukraine in in die
Europäische Union würde auch bedeuten
dass die Europäische Union sich deutlich
ändern musste denken ganz Europäische
Parlament denken an
Entscheidungsmechanismen und und und und
und und also dieser Prozess oder ein
viel größeren Veränderungsprozess auch
seitens der EU voraussetzen umgekehrt
macht die EU natürlich oder die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten natürlich unglaublich
viel jetzt auch gerade der munitionsstil
da ist viel am laufen also die Aufnahme
in die NATO wäre strukturell einfacher
zum Teil weil wir ja zusammen lernen der
Westen lernt gerade mit der Ukraine
zusammen das heißt die
Sicherheitsgarantien die einfließen
würden in einen NATO Ukraine Rat das
wäre ja da wo man diese
Sicherheitsgarantien faktisch umsetzt
und wo man aneinander lernt und auch
Entscheidungsmechanismen miteinander
macht das wäre einfacher aber wie man
ein Land was gegebenenfalls gespalten
ist was kriegerisch ist was es wäre
Auswirkungen auf Artikel 5 hat all diese
schwierigen Fragen die stehen in vilius
alle im Raum
wie viel wichtiger oder gibt es
Prioritäten für die Ukraine was die
EU-Mitgliedschaft oder die NATO Mitglied
also das was ich in Gesprächen mit
meinen ukrainischen Partnerinnen höre
ist die ukrainische Sicht ganz klar also
NATO ist die Priorität und die EU ist
ein langer Weg auch aus den Gründen was
ich schon gesagt haben da die EU
Annäherung eine Menge von juristische
Arbeit vor sich ein ganz kleine also
EU-Beitritt sich vor zum Beispiel von
ganz juristische
von ganz juristischen Winkel
Blinkwinkel sorry dass die
Wasserqualität in der Ukraine überall
den EU-Standards entsprechen sollen dann
denken wir an kachowka disaster was die
Russen gemacht haben sind wir in der Tat
der Meinung das Wasserqualität
den EU-Normen entspricht nein soll es
dir ja genau so ist ihr den Weg in die
EU Bremsen wahrscheinlich nicht das
heißt es muss eine Menge von juristische
Arbeit gemacht werden aber nach ist
relativ und dazu
gehören eine Menge von Argumenten welche
nur scheinen Argumenten sind weil sie
die religiosen fast so religiösen Mantra
sind wie zum Beispiel zuerst hörten wir
keine Sicherheit in Europa ohne gegen
Russland nur mit Russland ist absolut
unbegründet jetzt hören wir
NATO-Beitritt nur nach Ende des Krieges
nicht während des Krieges warum denn wir
haben die Länder welche die Mitglieder
der NATO war und wie Deutschland wie die
Bundesrepublik oder wie Zypern welche
dann mit Teile ihrer Gebiete besetzt und
der Besetzung haben die Bundesrepublik
war zum Teil nicht nur besetzt von
soritz die war in juristischen
Kriegszustand mit der Sowjetunion
gewesen trotzdem wurde es aufgenommen es
gibt absolut in dem NATO in dem
nato-statut gibt es absolut kein Artikel
der sagt dass die Länder wo die Teile
der Gebiete besetzt sind nicht in die
NATO aufgenommen werden kann
1954 und 55 als es um die Verhandlung
gegen die die die Westdeutschland in die
NATO aufzunehmen kann die Grenzgebiete
klar sie haben am Anfang unserer Sendung
noch mal ganz wunderbar illustriert
worum es jetzt hier geht um diese Graben
und Stellungskämpfe wo überhaupt nicht
klar ist so irgendwelche Linien enden
würden ich glaube die große Gefahr ist
auch für die Ukraine wenn wir
gegebenenfalls zu dem Moment kommen
würden wo wir in irgendeiner Weise klare
Grenzen hätten und dieser Teil der
Ukraine dann in irgendeiner Art und
Weise in die NATO aufgenommen würde dass
das dann ein Status Quo gibt wir haben
ein Grundgesetz und keine Verfassung
weil wir immer noch darauf gepocht haben
dass wir wieder vereinigt werden als
eine gesamt Bundesrepublik da haben wir
einen Statut gefunden aber das ist in
diesem Fall nicht unbedingt gegeben also
ich glaube da muss man sehr sehr
vorsichtig sein historische Beispiele
sind hilfreich aber sie sind nicht
unbedingt übertragbar
ich bin selbst kein Ukrainer aber ich
bin ständig mit denen Kontakt aus der
Sicht der Ukraine keine so verhandelt
werden dass die Sicherheitsgrenze in der
NATO nur für die Gebiete gelten welche
Faktor unter Kontrolle der Ukraine
stehen das wäre entscheidende Punkt
warum weil ja das wären keine Punkte
warum weil
aber das ändert sich sicher ständig aber
wir können ja Moment wir können es immer
juristisch sagen bis zum Tag sowieso 20
12 Uhr und so weiter das ist kein
Problem wenn wir so machen dann sagen
wir dass jede Rakete wir eine
ukrainische Staat trifft ist ein auf
nato-gebiet ist und Russland wird das
nicht machen genauso wie Russland ist
nicht macht mit anderen Ländern und
sehen wir jetzt die Sicherheitsgarantien
für die Ukraine geben dann ist es eine
Einladung für Russland bis zu roten
Linien zu gehen da werden wir sicher das
Garantien geben dann wie sollen sie
heißen heißt es Russland darf nur zehn
Rakete gegen Russland pro Tag abschießen
oder nur gegen die Städte bis 100.000
Einwohner oder keine Schule treffen oder
oder nur die die Kraftwerke treffen wie
wird das funktionieren dann wird
Russland ausprobieren bis zur Grenze und
ein bisschen queren weil Russland weiß
wir wollen nicht so gerne ein uns
einmischen wenn wir uns nicht einmischen
können und der letzte Punkt
ich sehe nicht vor dass wir sofort nach
einem Überfall auf ein nato-land unter
der ganze Armee ins Feld schicken NATO
Artikel 5 sagt nur beratenden zur
Unterstützung und da gibt es sehr viel
sehr viel Spielraum
was Grundsätzliches muss man glaube ich
sagen es geht hier nicht um juristische
Feinheiten oder Finessen oder Gebiete
oder sonst irgendwas
Artikel 42/7 EU-Verträge das ist eine
eindeutige klare Beistandsverpflichtung
ja und zwar zwingend also stellen wir
uns vor die Ukraine wird EU-Mitglied das
heißt die EU würde sich den Krieg direkt
importieren wir werden ab dem Moment des
Beitritts werden EU-Staaten verpflichtet
beizustehen Entschuldigung
klar gesagt amerikanische Präsident das
ist Krieg ein Land im Kriegszustand kann
nicht NATO Mitglied werden das ist das
Dilemma da haben Sie Recht das gibt
natürlich Putin die Möglichkeit zu sagen
na gut wenn das so ist dann hätte ich
diesen Krieg vor Ort noch 10 15 Jahre
und damit ist das eingefroren das ist
genau die Situation
natürlich es gibt eine Ukraine aus
unserer Sicht auch juristisch
völkerrechtlich eindeutig ohne
Resolution dazu
also das können sie nicht einfach so vom
Tisch wischen es gibt eine Ukraine
Russland und Putin hat keinerlei Recht
irgendein Gebiete Ukraine als seines zu
betrachten aber genau das ist unser
Problem die NATO muss versuchen nicht in
diesen Krieg zu involviert werden genau
das wird versucht seit 16 Monaten aber
alles zu tun um die souveräne Ukraine zu
unterstützen damit das Land nicht
verloren geht das ist glaube ich dass
das Autos wo und genau darum geht es
beim Gipfel in der nächsten Woche und
diese Illusion zu erzeugen dass die
Ukraine sicherer werden würde wenn Sie
Mitglied wird in der EU in der NATO das
ist einfach ein gefährliches Spiel dass
wir glaube ich hier nicht spielen
sollten trotzdem braucht die Ukraine ja
Sicherheitsgarantien
die Frage wie man es ganz genau aus
ihrer Sicht was ist das was die Ukraine
da jetzt braucht und was ist man bereit
auch von Polen aus dann zu geben vor
allem Unterstützung also die
dieser Waffenlieferung die müssen nach
wie vorgehen weil Ukraine einfach muss
diese Möglichkeit haben sich so selbst
verteidigen aber ich finde
zumindest eine Perspektive
[Musik]
wie in Zukunft dieses Land soll agieren
auch gegenüber Europäische Union
NATO das ist das ist auch natürlich eine
entscheidende Punkt aber das was auch
sieht man das in Polen und Polen ich
werde so sagen wenn geht es um diese
Ostpolitik wo der letzte Jahren so ein
bisschen nachbeteiligt wir haben auch
gesehen dass diese Ostpolitik wurde in
Paris und Berlin so ein bisschen
getrieben und nicht den Litauen nicht in
Polen ähm
eine Eskalation durch Russland wenn es
stärkere Sicherheitsgarantien durch die
NATO gibt für die grüne man befürchtet
aber
in Polen wenn man sich nicht Politiker
anhört nur einfach die ganz normale
Leute es gibt es tatsächlich diese diese
Befürchtung und die die kann ich auch
nachvollziehen dass wenn man immer mehr
Putin erlaubt dann er wird einfach da
weitergehen und vielleicht nicht Polen
wird als nächstes Land aber wollen wir
mal da werden wollen wir die baltische
Länder die rein strukturell ein Problem
haben weil die haben einen großen Anteil
von russischen Bevölkerung das ist das
ist ja ein großes Problem also für die
Linse gerne vielleicht noch ein bisschen
breiter ziehen damit wir noch mal alles
auf den Tisch packen ich glaube die
Sicherheitsgarantien müssen vor allen
Dingen glaubhaft sein und sie müssen
funktional sein das heißt die Ukraine
muss integriert werden in
Entscheidungsprozesse der NATO sie muss
technologisch hochgerüstet werden wie
wir es bislang nicht geschafft haben
bislang schmeißen ihren anfangszeichen
an unser altes Gerät den Ukraine darüber
machen aber nicht unbedingt
Zeitraum liefern das heißt aber dass ich
Gesellschaften auf der anderen Seite im
Westen nämlich auf lange Zeit und viel
Geld und UML einstellen müssen die auch
unsere Gesellschaften beeinflussen wir
haben jetzt gerade ein
Haushaltsbeschluss gesehen der Herren
Pistorius eigentlich den Haushalt noch
mal zusammenkürzt zwei Prozent wären 71
Milliarden Euro jetzt kommen aber nur
unterm Strich 52 Milliarden raus das
gleiche mit dem Sondervermögen aus aber
das sind alles Rechenspiele die nicht
besonders lang halten dabei muss aber
das was die Ukraine hören muss damit die
Sicherheitsgarantien funktionieren ganz
integriert stark und glaubhaft sein das
werden für die NATO Mitgliedsländer
versuchen vor dem Gipfel untereinander
noch zu klären NATO Mitgliedschaft aber
ist genau der Punkt der noch mal hier
die ganz großen Fragen stellt da ist es
ein eine zeitliche Frage und es ist eine
Frage der Definition von Artikel 5 weil
natürlich könnten wir quasi in
Anführungszeichen den Artikel 5 Sack
wieder aufmachen und den versuchen neue
juristisch zu verhandeln das heißt wenn
sie reinkämmen und es auf ein Angriff
auf ein nato-territorium in der Ukraine
abzählen würden das dann gegebenenfalls
eine bestimmte Länder Beistand leisten
und und und und und und aber es weicht
meiner Meinung nach das letzte
multilater mal noch ständig und stetig
funktionierende Gremium weil die UN das
ist durch verschiedene
Aspekte ist die ungeschwächt das würde
die Glaubwürdigkeit der NATO bis ins
Unendliche aufweichen und dann ist alles
vom Tisch also das heißt diese
sequenzierungen hinzubekommen das ist
wirklich wirklich kompliziert und es
wird auch in diesem Gipfel in dem Sinne
nicht gelöst werden aber die
Sicherheitsgarantien erstmal auf eine
wirkliche Ebene zu stellen und das eben
auch umgekehrt dass alle
Verteidigungsminister und alle
Premierminister und alle Präsidenten die
zurückkommen aus Velos das mit ihren
eigenen Gesellschaften ausmachen und
ordentlich kommunizieren das ist nämlich
die nächste große das wäre nämlich auch
nochmal eine Frage Lehmann sie sind ja
Korrespondent hier in Berlin wie erleben
sie denn die Diskussion um diesen Krieg
in Deutschland gerade auch im Vergleich
zu ihrem Heimatland also sehen sie dass
da die Unterstützung auch in der
Gesellschaft weiter stark bleibt oder
gibt es auch eine Befürchtung dass sie
sagen vielleicht bröckelt das auch also
das sind zwei komplett andere Ländern
also wenn mir wenn wir uns anschauen in
Deutschland so besonders aus Deutschland
wo dieses Bezug zum Russland war immer
sehr groß und wenn man vergleicht zum
Beispiel solche Länder wie Rumänien
Tschechoslowakei damals und Polen und
Ostdeutschland dass dieses Verhältnis
zum Russland in diesen Länder war anders
als in Ostdeutschland und muss ich
ehrlich sagen
man sieht einfach
zumindest die neue Umfragen auch von
einer Freundin von mir die die die sein
Barometer gemacht hat wegen Polen und
Deutschland war sie denken über über
Ukraine nach wie vor sieht man das
Mehrheit den beiden Ländern will die
Unterstützung für Ukraine aber in
Deutschland das tatsächlich sein singt
und einfach
[Musik]
man sieht das in beiden Ländern einfach
die Leute ganz klar schon müde sind und
die einfach dieses Krieg empfinden als
eine von vielen Nachricht das ist nicht
so wie vor einem Jahr deswegen durch die
berichtete auch über diesen Gipfel
natürlich noch mal sich verändern also
mit mehr womit rechnen Sie daher Meyer
also Richtung Deutschland EU oder auch
ihre Heimatland Österreich das
gefährlichste wenn die Europäer das
Gefühl hätten wir wollen damit nichts
mehr zu tun haben die Ukraine sollen
sozusagen machen was sie wollen und wir
wollen daraus wollen Frieden ich glaube
es ist umgekehrt wir sollten uns darauf
einstellen dass der Konflikt sehr lange
dauern wird und unsere Unterstützung für
die Ukraine zunehmen muss und zwar
schnell zunehmen muss weil man muss das
ganze auch von der umgekehrten Seite her
denken Sie schon mal angeklungen stellen
wir uns vor die Ukraine bricht zusammen
silenski wird ermordet was auch immer
und Russland gelingt es tatsächlich
dieses riesige Land einzunehmen ja sie
haben sofort den Moldawien sind bald
gekommen unmittelbar an Grenzen an der
EU autokonfliktionen und das sollten wir
uns nicht wünschen und deswegen müssen
wir uns engagieren ob uns das gefällt
oder nicht
Punkt das ja nur weil wir den Luxus der
Amerikaner immer noch im Rücken haben
die indispansible Nation ja fast 42
Millionen Dollar Milliarde Dollar das 42
Hilfspaket jetzt schon was ist wenn die
Wahl ganz anders ausgeht und darauf
spielt Vladimir Putin er hat sein Auge
sein Argusauge auf den November 2024
gerichtet denn wenn
in Amerika der Boden rausfällt dann hat
er leicht zu stehen
am Ende der Sendung denn jetzt sind sie
liebe Zuschauer liebe Zuhörerinnen jetzt
dran einige haben wir hier schon äh die
sich schon gemeldet haben ich würde
gerne das Wort geben Herrn Karl-heinz
Zahn aus Leipzig schönen guten Tag
wunderschönen guten Tag Köln
sehr interessant verfolgt kann aber mit
ihr das Kontinen nicht
beißen es gibt auf unseren Planeten ganz
andere Herausforderungen die wir haben
ganz andere und da können wir uns beim
besten Willen müssen wir hier mit diesem
Konflikten müssen endlich wir haben
Probleme in den kommen auf uns in den
nächsten Jahren
lösen können und da können wir uns
sicher was trinken in solche
Kleinigkeiten beim besten Willens tut
mal Leid und haben sie noch eine
konkrete Frage Herr Zahn an einen guten
konkret wir stellen Sie sich denn das
vor wie wollen wir denn den Klimawandel
jetzt bewältigen wir haben jetzt heute
schon wieder fast 40 Grad das wird sogar
garantiert nicht weniger es wird nicht
zurückgehen viele Menschen weit nach
drunter und die Opferzahlen für die wir
mit unserer Industrialisierung mit
unserer ungehemmten globalisieren
Industrialisierung
werden weiter steigen wie stellen Sie
sich das vor wir wollen wir das lösen
wenn wir solche kleinen Konflikte nicht
lesen können eine Frage hätte warum
nicht möglich wäre es
nicht lesen ein globale Sicherheitsnetz
entwickeln
wer möchte
sterben dann ist es bestimmt kein kein
kleiner geografischer Konflikt das
erstmal dazu das zweite ist dass wir
natürlich weiterhin multilaterale
Organisation und multilaterale Ebenen
brauchen um ganz klar globale Probleme
anzugehen aber das angesprochen dass
quasi ein ecozieht der ausgelöst wird
durch das Sprengung eines Staudamms
durch die Überflutung von vielen
Gebieten dass dadurch noch mal
agrarschätze ruiniert werden die ein
Land die die 54 Länder in Afrika in
Anführungszeichen dringend brauchen auch
in anderen Kriegsgebieten dringend
gebraucht werden all diese Dinge hängen
zusammen das heißt man kann die Lösung
die potenzielle Lösung der
transnationalen multilateralen Probleme
nicht trennen von einem Kriegsgeschehen
in der Ukraine auch wenn es bestimmte
Länder in der Welt gerne würden das
heißt für die in Anführungszeichen noch
existierenden Führungsmächte in dieser
Welt nämlich der Europäischen Union aber
eben auch den demokratischen Partner im
inopazifik und der USA muss es daran
liegen diese Dinge zusammen zu denken
und zusammen zu lösen anders wird es gar
nicht gehen Ich würde gerne den nächsten
Zuhörer zu Wort kommen lassen das ist
Dieter
aus Bruchsal wenn das stimmt die Katze
so ist das ja grüße Sie
bitte schon ihre Frage ja
soweit ist die Bevölkerung nach einer
Rückeroberung der ostukreise und der
Grimm rechtlich oder es steht orientiert
um auch eine NATO bei zugeführt worden
danke für diese Frage es ist in der Tat
sehr wichtig zu verstehen was ist der
Bevölkerung dort geht in den zurzeit von
Russland besetzten Gebieten und wir
Gebieten welche durch die ukrainische
Armee befreit werden ich war vor zwei
vor drei Wochen in der Ukraine und
sprach dort mit den Leuten welche
soziologische Umfragen in den
befreienden Gebieten machten das ist
eine unendliche Geschichte von der
Resilienz der Ukraine Rennen worden
viele ukraineerinnen welche dort wohnten
und von Russen okkupiert worden waren
die erzählen dass sie erst unter der
Okkupation verstanden haben welches Wert
für Sie die Frage Ukraine hatte sie
haben viele begonnen ganz demonstrativ
zum Beispiel medizinisch zu sprechen auf
den Straßen weil trotz der Tatsache dass
sie wussten dass das Probleme für sie
verursachen kann weil sie das als ein
Zeichen der Resilienz hatten und so
weiter und so fort sie die zivilen
Strukturen haben sich bewiesen die frei
gewählten Bürgermeisterin Bürgermeister
das konnten die Russen nie begreifen
warum die Ukraine die russischen
eingesetzten Leiter akzeptieren weil die
Russen selbst keine Demokratie kannten
und sie wussten nicht dass die
Bürgermeisterin Bürgermeister Respekt
genießen also zu Ihrer Frage diese Leute
wollen zurück in die Ukraine die
ukrainischen Truppen werden mit Blumen
und mit Umarmungen empfangen in diesen
in diesen Dorfen und stecken und diese
Leute welche zurückkommen die sind super
froh dass sie wirklich frei von diesem
Terror von Vergewaltigungen
Exekutionen und Untersuchungen sind ich
würde gerne ein bisschen kürzer am Tisch
damit es auch viele Zuhörerinnen und
Zuschauer hier zu Wort kommen können
Wilfried Walter Cup aus Polen bitte
schön
schönen guten Tag ich sehe die ganze
Lage so dass ich keine Alternative gibt
für Aufnahme mit der Ukraine in die
Natur weil die Ukraine verteidigt genau
diese Werte für diesen Freiheit und
Demokratie
ist das wenn man sagt ja wir sind dafür
wir sagen wir betonen ja so stark immer
diese westlichen Werte dann wäre es doch
konsequent zu sagen ich stimme Ihnen
explizit zu das gilt sowohl für die NATO
als auch für die Europäische Union das
sind zwei Organisationen die natürlich
für Freiheit für Demokratie für den
rechtsstift für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
stehen das Problem ist nur das haben wir
ja versucht in der Diskussion zu zeigen
wollen wir uns in diesen Krieg aktiv
involvieren und zwar als als EU-Länder
als NATO-Länder wir dürfen nicht
vergessen im Moment sind 22 von 27
EU-Ländern Mitglied der NATO mit
Schweden sind dann 23 sind noch ganz
ganz wenig mit Österreich und Zypern und
Alter die dann nicht dazu gehören und
das ist das dass die Lämmer von dem wir
stehen wenn ich vielleicht kurz
reduzieren darf auf den ersten
Fragesteller ich verstehe das sehr gut
dass man sagt lösen wir doch diese alle
diese Militär Bündnisse auf und wir
möchten eine globale Friedensordnung
haben
ich glaube jeder Mensch der der
einigermaßen gutwillig ist würde sich
das wünschen das Problem ist nur
Wladimir Putin und Russland hat genau
diesen Traum zerstört das war genau der
Traum warum die Vereinten Nationen nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gegründet worden
sind es ist Russland das im Moment in
Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen
vollkommen blockiert hat die UNO ist
völlig hilflos in dieser Situation und
das ist die Realität also wir können
träumen vom Frieden in der Zukunft aber
ich glaube wir müssen zur Kenntnis
nehmen wir leben in einer realen Welt in
der Gegenwart und die sieht gerade in
Europa nicht sehr schön aus und wir
müssen uns entscheiden was wir wollen
wofür wir kämpfen wollen und das ist im
Moment am Verhandlungstisch und das wird
auch das Thema sein nächste Woche beim
NATO Gipfel ich würde gerne Uwe scharf
zu Wort kommen lassen als Bad aus Bad
Salzungen schönen guten Tag Herrschaft
ja bitte schön ja also eine Frage
geteilt in zwei Gruppen und zwar
Finnland Schweden Mitten die Natos den
bayerischen Staaten an der Nordgrenze
von Finnland und Mann Raketen
abschusseinschlag in Sekunden die
baltische Flotte von Russen ist so gut
wie tot die Nordmeerflotte auch
NATO Grimm die Amerikaner würden dort
ebenfalls ihre Station für Kriegsschiffe
machen die schwarz mehr Flotte tut gehen
Sie jetzt davon aus dass Kuba eventuell
unter den Schutz von den Russen wollte
raketenstationieren oder die momentan
unmögliche Variante das Hawaii aus dem
Bundesstaaten von Amerika aussteigen
wollte und die Pazifikflotte der
Amerikaner nach draußen bittet was würde
passieren also sind würde dann
unterschiedlich die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen von großen
strukturiert und die von Amerikanern wie
auch immer was ist da gemeint oder
gemacht ja also ich sehe hier so keine
Parallelen wir wissen dass ein NATO und
EU-Mitglied Ungarn seit Jahren eine
explizit pro russische Politik führt und
keine
us-luftlandungsdivisionen Budapest
landet um Herrn Orban abzusetzen wir
wissen dass Großbritannien aus den aus
der EU ausgetreten ist wir haben der
Großbritannien nicht mit unseren
Divisionen bedroht und so weiter und so
fort also das Problem ist dass Russland
nicht nur das irgendwelche Länder in den
Russland Wohlen oder das sind
gefährliche Länder in die NATO wollen
der Probleme heute das Problem heute ist
das Russland einen genozidaten Krieg
gegen die Ukraine führt dass
hunderttausende Kinder nach russischen
Angaben verschleppt worden waren das ist
ein Bestandteil des Genozids nach der
UNO Konvention was Russland auch
unterzeichnet ist und nicht ausgetreten
ist wir dass die Gebieter dreimal so
groß wie Österreich in der Ukraine
vermint sind wir wissen dass ein
kachowka Staud am See dreimal größer als
Bodensee zerstört ist mit den flutigen
ganz bewusst wir wissen dass ein
Atomkraftwerk mitten in Europa das
größte Atomkraft mehr vermehrt wird und
die Russen uns bedrohen dass in die Luft
in die Luft zu jagen das sind das
Problem und nicht das irgendwie ja
Moskau Wodka gerne hat als Kentucky
Whisky das ist das Problem okay ich
würde gerne Gerald soll sich das Wort
geben aus Halle an der Saale versorgt
schönen guten Tag hallo guten Tag ihre
Frage ja meine Frage ist was wäre das
Zauber wird der NATO Beitritt das hat ja
der Herr aus ist Österreich sehr gut
zuletzt erklärt und ich freue mich über
die Argumentation die der Herr ist da
keine etwas positive etwas optischer
sieht aber
merkt man nicht dass hier die Ukraine
als Spiel bei mir tun die Leute ganz
ganz leicht und es ist abscheulich was
passiert aber merkt man nicht dass man
die Ukraine in Machtkampf hier NATO
weiter als Spielball fast wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg benutzt merkt man das nicht
und warum können doch keine Lösung sein
für
Friedensgespräche und hilft dann
wirklich das Zauberwort Nachdruck
wer möchte wie sehen sie es also
natürlich immer auf wellenkrieg wir
haben die zwei oder drei Parteien und
immer Politik hier spielt eine Rolle
aber wichtigste ist das jetzt dieses
Krieg im in der Ukraine zu beenden
einfach dieses Schrecken zu beenden und
das ist das ist ein Priorität weil wir
brauchen einfach in Europa ein Frieden
wir brauchen einfach wieder ein Wachstum
und wir müssen auch dann Ukraine einfach
Chance ergeben selbst bestimmen über die
Zukunft dieses Landes es kann einfach
nicht sein dass andere Ländern einfach
sein großes Einfluss nur nehmen weil die
finden das die Historie und die
Geschichte zeigt dass die Ukraine war
ein Teil von Sowjetunion wir müssen
einfach dazu führen dass die Ukraine
selber entscheiden welche Richtung gehen
wollen die müssen auch natürlich nach
dem Krieg einfach ihre Aufgaben erfüllen
aber wir müssen als Europäer einfach
dieses Gefühl geben dass es ein
souveränerland ein souveräner
Entscheidungen trifft und souverän
entscheidet was will in Zukunft haben da
wenn ich mir so viel Zeit haben aber ich
würde dann doch noch die Frage von Herrn
Peter Menzel dazu Vorlesen er sagt warum
bietet man Russland nicht an dass man ab
sofort keine Waffen mehr in die Ukraine
liefert und Russland im Gegenzug den
Krieg beendet anschließend müsste man
dann hart verhandeln vielleicht jetzt
noch mal einfach zum Schluss Frau
klüveresch also ich meine Chance jetzt
auch nach dem NATO-Gipfel was sie in
keiner Episode auch nicht bei den
Verhandlungen zum Weizen Deal als wie
man im englischen sagt als anders Broker
als ehrlicher Verhandlungspartner
dargestellt oder aufgestellt das haben
wir schon bei den Minsker Verhandlungen
gesehen also das finde ich weiterhin
unglaublich schwierig ich glaube die
Situation ist einfach die dass wir
wirklich die Ukraine bis ans Ende ihres
vermeintlichen Kriegsziel ist nämlich
die Befreiung ihre eigenen Territorien
unterstützen müssen schnell mit dem
entsprechenden Gerät und auf Zeit
also hier dazu muss man sagen dass über
80 Prozent der Ukrainerinnen sagen sie
wären bereit zu kämpfen auch wenn sie
keine Unterstützung von Westen haben 90
Prozent der Ukraine Rennen sagen sie
wären bereit zu kämpfen auch wenn sie
Russen ein atomaren Schlag gegen die
Ukraine ausüben das ist das Niveau der
Entscheidung zu kämpfen was wir in
Deutschland gar nicht kennen weil sie
Ukraine um ihre Freiheit und und ihre
Leben kämpfen und sie wissen was mit den
passiert wenn sie Russen die Oberhand
gewinnen Vergewaltigung Exekutionen
Auslöschung der ukrainische Nationen
deswegen die Ukraine mit einem Spielball
zu vergleichen ist vollkommen weg von
der Realität die Ukraine wollen in die
NATO nicht weil sie gespielt werden
sondern weil sie in der NATO die Hilfe
und den Unterstützung sehen und sie
werden miteinander oder ohne NATO
kämpfen mit unseren Waffen oder ohne sie
weil sie wissen sie kämpfen für ihre
eigenes Überleben als die Nation und
jeder als eine Person
diese Woche was ist überhaupt erw für
die Ukraine nach diesem Gipfel also
meine haupterwartung ist dass die NATO
wie wir vorher auch schon gesagt haben
sich viel stärker aufstellen wird dass
die Europäer eine sehr viel größere
Rolle spielen in den nächsten Jahren als
sie bisher gespielt haben wir stehen vor
einer Phase der
Militarisierung durchaus wie wir das
seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr gesehen
haben ich glaube dass die Europäer die
Ukraine nicht aufgeben dürfen und können
und wir müssen den Druck auf Putin und
Moskau erhöhen soweit dass nur irgendwie
geht wir sind gespannt auf diesen
NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius und Berichten
natürlich bei Phoenix ganz ausführlich
darüber und am Mittwochabend gibt es
auch noch mal eine Sonderausgabe der
Phönix Runde dazu sie werden also rund
um informiert Ihnen noch einen schönen
Tag auch den Zuhörenden
[Musik]
alle Tiere stehen vor den gleichen
Herausforderungen Partner